welcome to this video playing rati rati
from australia and ratty when we play
the Rigi something like that ok let's
complete here White's double fianchetto
and ok we transpose to possibly the head
shocked if he goes for d 6 a-6 mark
doesn't write c 6 that's not too common
it's not a not bad though probably rip n
sorry I'm got a slight cold maybeee form
C for an option I if I go D for
exchanges to be too much like both
knights and bishops term may be here
with d4 there's a bit more bit more bite
to to the whole position
I am ok it's still pretty much a regular
Hedgehog I can try for a quick Bishop e3
operation maybe I look do you one yeah
yeah this one on the other I don't know
maybe I a4 a5 as an option so go for a
rook f.2d one this 3 after he threatened
e5 but he has some addressed that I
wonder a four a five that's not too
common but the the situation here is a
bit different compared to some other
hedgehogs because um when there's one
pair of nights exchanged and he has not
yet played a six I wonder how it looks
this looks rather interesting
ok
yeah should I take or or not yeah okay
now if you place b5 now there might be
five not maybe I'm not sure this is
technically possible even because of d5
gel is not believing any of that v5 de 5
I would i but it is good yeah I can just
I can just play Quincy one with a double
attack and the twins material now it is
unless I'm screwing up the calculation
terribly okay but you guys have now ok
so now this issue this should win
material please don't tell me I've
miscalculated him
yeah it's essentially a double attack
black resigned yeah it just uses
material he cannot play b5 what was it
been surprised how quickly he went for
it because it was true gay 6 is pretty
much telephoning my tensions here but ok
played it anyway let's sir let's see it
it's really losing him with 35 or not ah
the computer are interesting in yeah it
seems to be good for white but it's not
like I have I believed it is it can take
and go here which I overlooked am
covering g2 and attacking the rook after
the capture however i can take here and
i am much better because of the the bed
king position it's an extra porn also
but the main problem is that blacks king
site is so compromised and there is
suspicion raging across the board so ok
b5 wasn't great after all the computer
however is already pretty skeptical
about blacks position it wants to play
Queen c7 which ones know what I expected
and then we move like a group de one da
one intending would be 7 and 23 going
it's just pretty good for white
computers on plus 1.3 or something it's
pretty it's pretty comfortable this is
some a bit more a bit more comfortable
than usual I here could have played a 5
as well oh this is a bad miss actually i
was i was playing this hard to crooklyn
the normal retreat i can just go here
the queen is RD 700 c 7 yeah that sets
almost winning look at this no black
hair
this is probably the best defense this
is an excellent position for white yeah
it's not a winning but it's it's very
good very good okay maybe this is this
always let's do something he could maybe
take this is also possible and go a6 and
this a six point is a weakness but it is
not so easily won by white alright
thanks for watching